So, thank you for listening and watching this course today, hopefully it's covered a lot
of ground in terms of looking at your subsurface and your parallax occlusion.
We dug into the different layered materials, looking at the older ways, also the newer
ways, but also how you might introduce mega scans into your projects as well.
And then that material parameter collection section, hopefully it just gives you a few
more ideas about how you might control these effects at runtime.
Maybe it's using a sequencer, or maybe you want to bring these material parameter collections
into a blueprint eventually.
However you want to approach them, there's plenty of further documentation out there.
So thank you very much for your time today, and we'll see you in the next course.